there were signs of trouble indianapolis
police say the 18 year old accused of
killing eight people at a fedex
warehouse was reported as a mental
health risk
by his own family authorities say
brandon hole took his own life after the
attack
investigators learned he bought two
rifles even after his family warned
police he was a mental health risk
indiana's red flag law allows a judge to
keep a person like that from buying a
gun
and it should have stopped him but he
wasn't on the list mike lawler helped
create the nation's first red flag law
in connecticut in 1999
he says red flag laws need to make the
involvement of a judge
mandatory to prevent these tragedies the
indiana statute
is affected in the moment they can grab
the gun but there's no follow-up right
there's no mandatory follow-up it's very
discretionary and it's easy for things
like this to fall through the cracks
investigators are still trying to
determine a motive for the attack
including whether
hate played a role several victims
belong to the chic community there in
indianapolis